Because i think that what i wanted to make was right. To do. Just google.
Because it's a very long while you know i was young but i would have to be two.
And then if you're drawn into where you have to go from got a game to this it's great to be a mile up with another.
Two more than that guy. That would come to your brother would to get him to think about that you know the clock tool.
Pretty much. How many.
Probably twenty something like that i can tell you i have no problem at all good luck to him always good luck with the
i think that we're trying to speak italian but of course. Not knowing that with my brother going into a few scrapes.
And i will tell you. Cool teachers. School teacher was just adorable. And he had a little kids. Little boy.
And my brother was real good. All of taught. And this little kid coming down was teasing him.
So he picked him up and put him up for banning the french have really turned him around the guys.
Back three months time. We were in effect. And i think out it shouldn't do that but with us now it was pretty good.
But. When i think you put a lot.
I think you realize that we were terry and because of that he felt good and i thought that you probably put up with.
What he might know. Them with another. Of a trial probably. That's just my impression. And what.
Just my mind just because i'm grateful. You know now that. You know that nobody here.
You know that will call the roll call. You keep in touch with them and. Not a friend.
Now and i'm saying the wrong thing i'd add an extra kept in touch but strangely enough. One of the boys.
That went to the school now with you straight to my boat from you and your sister used to go to.
Why haven't i have actually kept in touch but we made up i have also recently i've joined the bond dos authority
and through that i met another girl with him on this week. One thing. But actually having good contacts.
Actually let's hear me young. To get you guys who will probably come to that lie that.
We didn't get to the christmas tree. I remember going to the christmas tree which was absolutely magical.
For me because the minute you log on one time on your old uniform. On the legal bill to me.
And another time i was given a little doll that first started writing monologues. And i thought it was very beautiful.
Until my brother annette read it coming i haven't to say what it was you know. And it was. Drawl.
And i cried and cried i didn't want my doll to have straw in the coming.
And i don't know what happened to the government and they are probably people that no one. But you sort of played guy.
And things like that you know.
Santa kind which was to me was just something you know nothing like in ny were none of them none of them.
But it's one thing to have very much.
The reason i named for santa claus but that's really the phantom which means in life.
But i mean when you're poor you know. There's something very special next. History.
So you have sort of special diaries in them and i called across to the drawing. That. And that special. Courage and.
They still have a print and i have my per lot of women. Mike of course. Not that i'm really good at cooking on.
Rachel of course. Your the same of course the girl from your mother.
But we didn't have to be on the end of the bottle to do that when there were that more
or less the syme it was racial a carson. And another man made a quarter.
Which is nothing like the tour guide there were mine here. But it with my blood that that course from the pain.
I have since time out he has in mind if he
and i are agreeing with you you are the type to put it in religion to grab your mom out of court noise. And i thought.
Well i had living with my father and mother had contact with his mom right. To them right up till you'd have gone.
Oh you must make personal family. Do you have a. Well let me come back. That night with them and.
I found that more surprising than what i thought. If you have ever. Completely foreign news.
Are you switch to the same dollars. You would have and are probably different than in this thing. Are you.
That problem. No two just recently. And that you know it. Well. That was one of them.
You'd have was when the chips nuts were the monk how you know how one might have a hobby. Drinking wine and chestnut.
And it happened that we played both an airplane and one when we now want to think that this was so thrilled about it.
That i said i want to be celebrated. Since i was in your fill of dried up half life. Which is here.
And then it sort of went on from and someone said well why don't we make it a chestnut march which we did
and we had people kind of like the original ones would have been the ones that were in the committee.
And it was strange and they are sort of. Step back and look at them. And this is. This is just like a very.
And it brings back memories. And i regard them are very much you knew i wasn't very impressed.
Where did you get that from. But for in truth the guy being.
Actually more than you can come up with pretty critical of will. And then take them. But we turn to bob if you can.
To remember the first not. The algorithm. The hair grew little that were you know.
And that when you turn that on the first one. Probably ties because they're very expensive.
And the washing is a work of ox. And it used to be a kerosene tin and i can't remember how you kind of exactly.
But i think you would kind of ruin the top and bottom.
And then the saw a new one so i don't cotton to have it you could i tend to trying. Ground but.
I would say you wouldn't cut just so. One would use it for washing at one time for washing up.
And one thought for rinsing. Which might a terrific team and i had one of those for washing up. So yeah.
Could we have washed their hands and saw and we had a little bench outside. Like a laundry.
Sort of thing my two little tub and everyone had that because we use for a lot of english. Now i mean.
But they're not much of me don't go into the hands of the rich but i don't know where that matters.
From because i haven't i haven't been one are rotten with them
and i can remember several of his friends you know that having to do the dishes once a day. Now i think that was done.
Every day. And that was what you want to because you're looking at a fair. Government for how. Family. Sideline.
You in the order. Washing and that would be put on the day and you can remember on.
Turn your back after paris alarming out to what would what i would do. That would first be rinsed out and.
Any sort of scraps that came up your pride to met when. Towards the free from pain. Nothing was wise to.
Nothing but with the situation where did you watch the dishes to wash up every day
but the thing is that if it really rain shorts or record rain short actually.
You wouldn't get your water for washing up and for washing grounds from a creek. Or from a will.
I think you might have had a world cup. Because the country. Could you have.
You would have to get water from somewhere because that wouldn't do you say you. When you were running.
You can't keep them from drinking water little people from the family. Small plane.
And we start wondering whether would be a must.
Was a peak an expensive item when it wasn't going to carry expensive items because it was bought and you're right.
You still have a little piece in many of the scraps from the kitchen before feeding it grew around corn. So that was.
Into it and. The white from up to my room. Got a cherry tree.
But it was really inexpensive to feed in and it was very lives we could do for barry.
And it was very large for the killer.
And of course us children were made to go why it will make you all that
but are you taking this one paygo thing i'm going up to think it was very nice anyway. So i never looked again.
Just sausages. So mommy the sausages. Nothing that was cool with you two which your my with that wasn't the best.
And you put this you actually mean step.
The skin of the wrong
and the people who met the sausages in the call to give me a line in the first with my with the maid.
But have a little blood on it with something. And i would go in a very short time. Because they wouldn't take long.
That the salami liquidity would have to last too quickly or year.
And i had no preservatives in them at all what they did was that i dug how. Under the house.
And they put boards around it and turned it into a cellar. Yellow hair. From when i can remember.
It was under the house. And the law of the house was the top of the cellar.
But i was talking to my sister the other guy and she said there really really first one which i don't remember.
Was a big box in the family how dug in the ground and the big box was put there
and we kept it i don't remember that we put it in. And it had to be the coolest you could.
And he went awry and of course water when you do it. But you have to take the salami like a month and.
Start your viral order atlas and running it open and when it was drawn put them back in again because of.
Very important here because there were things that we had to have time for and that was enough to have we got better
and a bit more will have to play with that for us. And the crew to give you something that you call your actually.
It's called. Whereas some actually. If you didn't know one might go on.
It would give them our diversity
and that would help people draw i think you have a case that we know right from that that it was that would go out
there that night it didn't draw actually draw at all and. Tell you that you took. The lower leg which.
You don't want to use and i mean because they're not they're not to roll.
So you get all that and then you get the wrong one from the people that thought actually a thing to get from italy.
To the things that would means that i have and i would put you in bed.
And it would actually give you one skin because it's the appendix.
There that you would have to top the bottom of the boat and.
It's already ran and put it in very tightly you taught your cool because you want to create that.
And then get hard on cult. Three strings around.
Harden and put a little how in one year somebody forgot to put how my old first lot
but then you'd hang them up to draw your name up in your kitchen actually
and to order it said get the bill before that but i don't know. What or love lasted long. Salami.
Yes because that ring the old one. Because you know that you couldn't get you the actual thing that.
It was getting all natural feelings toward the salami with. No that's not going to die i'm not here.
Looking good now but for the food them only natural.
Source of income has been a civil war in the mountains
and starting to be here shortly after we came up being before there wasn't a road up to the plantation.
So there have to be counted. With the horse and spring cowboy chap. That all remembers me.
He would pick them up and take them to the top of the very state heel and send them down the long folks.
And be the carrier. Jack brain with the carrier and he'd write down on the coffin came bryant. And he'd stop them.
Damn near. Put them on these trucks and take them into the right away to be sent to sydney. Yes.
Where are you remember one time. Somebody did somebody to get them applause. Prox. I wouldn't say it.
But i believe you
when they haven't really got to the bottom of this i want to find out that you're going to hear it with a very long
and. You know how you can read them to on the cards as martin.
Stopped in time on the something the kind that you write a lot. It was working the system you send something down.
In something awful things that i don't.
Exactly what process we're in the process for i'm actually going to be better than i were lighter got a little twirl
lighter. But bad that sometimes. Thirty forty cases of bigger crisis. Than what we have now.
Maybe half a dozen in the stands that get nothing out of that you had your production costs which christ.
Start up with you carry me to carry them i'm told it was very high. The only way we actually believe.
Because we were pretty self-sufficient. And that the target or not there were things that you had to boil and. From.
So i could remember there were shopkeeper in town jack. Or a jam or a you had a shop.
You know our industry was going on the railway station.
We had a shop there for a long time the two would live straight with the imperial.
And he would give credit to the italians.
And he carried it would carry them month after month you know
and probably wouldn't even ask for money because he didn't have any in the line. And also knew that it was very cool.
That would hire them. That women. And things like that that would get some money. Vegetables were a good proposition.
In that because that would be seem to suit me in them in the winter months where they couldn't grab them. So much and.
That would be worth money. That's. Rights of our very first time when they were planning to actually plant the brains.
In between the bananas. Which would give them a quick quick quick. Not just a go.
But tied to modern life can remember was right and right now. We cannot go before that.
Because that's been on the git go. So the better.
We should rather not start yelling which is why i wanted to log on which was on the top of a problem which we call.
The rod sometimes with a lighter on. Right. On the carrier coming to the f.a.a. Getting to the area.
But one toilet system was pregnant too and she had to get probably. And the anyway the guy with the carrier or.
This guy. My mother when you sit down. She was sitting in the front and. She had to sit on top of the light.
And i think just a little part of. Forward to see. The keiser.
Something that she was told to remember because she was probably like you want to think i got someone to help them.
You have to work. The more you. Don't. Which would be daunting and it was placed in the school.
Where once again they were to bring the girls to the kitchen for lights in the bathrooms.
On the corner of the brain that you were going to get you could. She never called for. She always had a star.
You still didn't have many italians.
Around him all the time lives are on some kind
but never anyone close close to is not just a thing as a child growing up was very lonely because we had not had no
other children. Like brother nars.
But i was the one that was always getting into trouble with the little child being me. And then i can be trouble.
Trouble. What kind of punishment. Except for you. Yelling at me helping dad that were very much. Kids and not.
You know. Very much that they're actually my father and. Little mom not at all.
But i just remember place that's where my other sister my sister got married from my friends with two daughters who
were different down the road during ruby. And one of them. Did the most beautiful very fun stuff that i did the same.
So i haven't seen anybody even if i haven't seen the scene.
And she had asked him to do what i imagine my ass to do
and it wouldn't have been she done all this question for my sister who was going to get married when it got.
I put it all out on the bay and it covered the how bad and. Up on to realize. And it was absolutely beautiful.
And moss just to had all this. In our head not going.
How i really do you see
nor can remember telling us to get married then why would we want to have to fix you take your car for two anyway i
think that guy and me want to keep me quiet in that arc and during member heroin or you know dollars from the label.
And never having seen anything like that you know she got married. And she was being twenty two years.
I can really still hold its treasure and i am nothing. And what was what was she having done.
Well apparently she'd been the name just before so you know i think she needed more feelings.
But she decided she wasn't going to happen because she was getting married soon.
So i said jeannette spend the money on her but the other tellings we can use are the ones that you do. Come across.
Did you understand. At that time more or less kind. From the sign. Place. From northern italy.
That could have things that i didn't come in contact with them. So i really don't know. But probably the syrians.
Would have spoken to tell you the true ten. Which my parents would have understood. I didn't. The time i do now.
But at the time when. So you're taught. Well i didn't actually teach me in dollars.
We were just five dollars at the time it wasn't actually taught what to tell you nothing. And the crew. Because.
Not a very complicated.
Conversation i mean you go to a lawyer
and my status very very probably will know what that word about myself on the line. I can understand that.
Did you probably actually hear that he was from behind me too. Very much ram and.
The families knew each other they were just the family lived or a brother did come. His brother but that's all.
I think up got to the school a copy came. Where our winters no longer.
It is for the dam right now to go to work in their lives.
I don't know what year it was year one and all the school records were lost there some people have a few fires
and i do have a practical. Became a long summary rather than have one of the. Three or four of us were going to school.
They're headed for trouble and the cops came because there wasn't a road to coffee.
What we'd have to get was for have a go with a carrier. All of the time. You.